[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
conan o'brien here uh
here's what's going on in my world
uh wow i'm so psyched about the new fast
and furious six
which is opening soon
and and this first segment is my tribute
to the fast and furious movies
uh it's called vin diesel in more
sensible forms of transportation
vin diesel in more sensible forms of
transportation
here's vin diesel riding a city bus
hearing
carpooling with co-workers
he's wearing a safety belt and here's
vin on a recumbent bicycle
vin diesel in more sensible forms of
transportation will diesel in more
sensible forms of transportation
this next segment's called baby don't
want to hear that baby don't want to
hear that
this is where i replace the sound in
squeezable baby toys with sounds babies
don't really want to hear
go to bed now
go to bed now
go to bed now
dammit
baby don't want to hear that
so everybody's talking about this
british actor in the new star trek movie
benedict cumberbatch
there he is everybody's talking about
him yeah
people are saying like he's the sexiest
british guy ever but there are other
british guys
way sexier than benedict cumberbatch
that's why this next segment's called
sexier than benedict cumberbatch
sexier than benedict cumberbatch
check out these sexy british guys
there's brinkley dribble snatch
there's whisper pippin stix
[Applause]
there's bluster b digging clue
there's fognacious quash
[Applause]
and lord percival pudge pickle
[Applause]
now it's time to check in really fast
with my friend andy i don't know where
he is so i'm going to invite him in for
a uh video chat right now see if i can
do that
hey andy hi connor what are you doing
i'm doing my video blog what are you
doing oh just eating some cheetos
watching a video of a naked russian guy
beating up a cop
andy is that who i think it is on the
poster behind you go back there
you bet [ __ ] nature's squash rules yeah
cool see you later andy bye all right
cool
all right this last segment is called
animals that sound like people no
animals
[Applause]
i know you like them shut up
that's right animals that sound like
people here's a lizard
[Music]
here's
here's a polar bear
[Music]
and here's an eagle
whoa
all right that was my latest video blog